20 mars 2001 la californie est encore
plongée dans le noir
c'est le troisième black out qui
frappent la californie en l'espace d'un
an après ceux du 14 juin 2000 et du 17
janvier 2011
cette fois ce sont un million et demi de
californiens qui n'ont plus accès à
l'électricité
pire encore depuis avril 2000 les prix
de l'électricité ne cessent de flamber
tellement que pour éviter de ruiner les
plus pauvres l'état californien a
préféré s'endetter et payer une grosse
partie de l'électricité à la place du
consommateur
le coût de cette crise majeure de
l'électricité est estimé à 40 milliards
de dollars
mais comment le prix de l'état cités
at-il pu augmenter ainsi que s'est il
passé en californie
entre avril 2010 et mars 2011
les causes de cette crise sont multiples
à commencer par une augmentation de la
population et donc de la demande en
électricité mais surtout le marché de
l'électricité californien a subi une
dérégulation partiel qui change est
grandement le jeu que jouent les
producteurs et les distributeurs
d'électricité en particulier les traders
des compagnies de production pouvait
désormais éteindre leurs centrales à des
instants de forte consommation pour
créer une raréfication soudaine de
l'électricité et ainsi provoquer une
inflation des prix
alors avant que vous ne vous laissiez
emporté par votre organisme
anticapitaliste insiste sur le fait que
le marché de l'électricité californien à
de nombreuses spécificités qui font que
dans ce cas là la dérégulation partiel a
été une très très mauvaise idée
en vrac on peut citer le fait que le
marché de l'électricité à une grande
barrière à l'entrée
et oui construire une centrale
électrique c'est pas donné à la start up
du coin pire encore les procédures
administratives d'autorisation à la
construction ont été longues et ont subi
beaucoup de délais de le marché de
l'électricité est en temps réel
ça ça vient du fait que l'électricité ne
peut pas être stockée alors oui les
batteries ça existe en 2001 elle n'était
capable de stocker qu'une infime portion
de l'électricité produite et du coup les
prix de l'électricité réagissent en
temps réel en particulier dès qu'un
producteur et dans une centrale
la raréfication de l'électricité est
immédiate ce qui fait instantanément
flamber le prix de écrit six t3 la
demande en électricité est innée
élastique ça ça veut dire qu'une
variation du prix de l'électricité ne va
pas affecter la consommation comme l'a
affirmé david freeman alors directeur de
l'autorité pour l'énergie californiennes
viennent de leçon fondamentale qu'il
faut absolument apprendre de cette
expérience
l'électricité est très différente de
tout autre bien mais si je vous raconte
tout ça ce n'est pas pour vous parler
d'électricité je veux surtout insisté
sur l'autre leçon fondamentale souligné
par le même freeman tout système qui
peut être manipulé sera manipulé et ce
au pire moment
autrement dit de façon plus générale
quand on conçoit un système il faut
absolument se demander comment les
parties prenantes du système vont
pouvoir l'attaquer et tirer parti de
façon malhonnête du système et cette
problématique n'est pas du tout
spécifique ni à l'électricité ni même au
marché économique par exemple dans le
sport aussi tricher peut flirter avec
bien joué
quand il ya des phases de poules dans
des compétitions sportives
certains matches peuvent compter pour du
beurre il peut même être préférable de
faire exprès de perdre c'est ainsi
qu'aux jeux olympiques de londres de
certaines joueuses de badminton ont tout
simplement cherché à perdre
le problème c'est que les deux équipes
se sont mis à vouloir perdre en même
temps ce qui a conduit à l'un des
spectacles sportifs les plus lamentables
de l'histoire puise à une
disqualification de toutes ces joueuses
et bien sûr ne le droit des remarques de
commentateur sportif sur les grandes
valeurs olympiques et l'importance de
toujours donner le meilleur de soi sauf
que bien sûr quand on regarde le sport
plus en détail on retrouve la
nonchalance des joueuses de badminton
dont bien d'autres sports dans ces mêmes
jeux olympiques
l'équipe d'espagne de basket ball père
nonchalamment contre le brésil est vite
du coup d'être dans la partie de tableau
des états unis et ira ainsi décroché une
médaille d'argent
toujours dans ces mêmes jeux olympiques
en demi finales du 100 mètres usain bolt
se relâchent complètement dans les
trente derniers mètres
cependant cette fois-ci les
commentateurs sportifs souligne son
intelligence de course
quelles que soient les valeurs
olympiques les athlètes qui s'en
sortiront le mieux seront ceux qui
gèrent leurs efforts et ne seront donc
pas toujours en train de donner le
meilleur d'eux mêmes
mais ces cas là sont encore des cas
gentil en 1994 michael schumacher a un
point d'avancé sur damon grill avant la
dernière course du championnat de
formule 1
mais du coup quand elle s'apprête à le
dépasser schumacher y voit l'occasion de
mettre fin aux chances de schumacher
finira dans les pneus mais il finira lui
aussi par devoir abandonner la course
grâce à l'accident qu'il aura causé
schumacher devient champion du monde
alors ça vous me direz ce n'est qu'un
événement ponctuel encore que schumacher
a tenté de faire la même trois ans plus
tard mais dans certains sports les
incentives conduisent à des
comportements immoraux l'écurie vous
l'attendiez janvier aux simulations
football et bien sûr ces simulations
presque tout le à l'intérieur de la
surface de réparation ou alors elle
espère inciter l'arbitré à sortir le
carton rouge
vous voyez le problème les gains à
tricher et tromper l'arbitré au football
sont énormes
comme il ya peu de buts marqués chaque
but à nu très grande valeur
or obtenir un penalty procure une très
grande chance de marquer un but de la
même façon un carton rouge pour
l'adversaire peut faire basculer un
match
notamment parce qu'un carton rouge est
définitif mais malgré sa réputation en
football mais peut-être pas le pire cas
le pire cas c'est peut-être davantage le
cas de la marche athlétique de façon
égale marcheurs athlétique doit avoir au
moins un pied au sol à tout instant sauf
que comme l'expliquent très bien minutes
physx des technologies minimaliste comme
les appareils photos que les juges n'ont
pas le droit d'utiliser montre que les
marcheurs sont en fait très souvent les
deux pieds en l'air près de 10% du temps
en fait pour le coup il est clair que
celui qui cherche à vraiment suivre les
règles de ce sport à la lettre pour à
plusieurs longueurs de retard sur le
champion dont le déhanché est
parfaitement huilé quoique techniquement
illégal alors loin de moi l'envié de
discréditer les marcheurs athlétique
ce sont des vrais athlètes et des vrais
champions ce que je veux montrer c'est
surtout que certaines règles ne
promeuvent pas du tout l'honnêteté et
l'éthique
en fait en général si on prend des
règles au hasard elles auront toutes les
chances de créer des initiatives qui
sont incompatibles avec les tic
mais du coup serait-il possible de créer
des incentive compatible avec l'éthique
ou dit autrement peut-on concevoir des
règles dites incentive comme patti bol
et bien de façon assez surprenante
la réponse est au moins en principe oui
mieux encore le principe dit de
révélations qui en fait n'est pas un
principe mais un théorème mathématique
affirme que toute règle joué de façon
si mal par des joueurs stratégique est
en fait essentiellement équivalente un
mécanisme où tout ce que l'on demande
aux joueurs c'est de nous révéler tout
ce qu'ils savent et veulent et pour
lequel et c'est ça le plus important
les joueurs ont toujours intérêt à être
honnête dans leurs révélations le
principe de révélations permet de
transformer n'importe quel mécanisme où
les joueurs se comportent de façon
malhonnête en un mécanisme équivalent ou
les joueurs auront tout intérêt à se
comporter de manière éthique et moral
alors ça peut paraître magique et
farfelu c'est loin d'être la sociaux à
tous les problèmes d'organisation de
société mais de façon amusante le
principe de révélation est en fait déjà
partiellement appliquée dans le monde de
la justice
en effet imaginons que vous deviez
défendre votre cas en procès le problème
c'est que vous n'avez pas forcément
intérêt à révéler tout ce que vous savez
du coup plutôt que de vous défendre en
utilisant potentiellement le mensonge la
justice vous propose d'embaucher un
avocat qui vous défendra comme vous
auriez aimé vous défendre
sauf que pour que celui-ci vous défendre
aussi bien que possible il vous faut lui
avait tout ce que vous savez et de façon
cruciale le privilège avocat clients
forcera votre avocat à ne jamais révéler
de ce que vous lui avez dit de sorte que
vous ayez bel et bien tout intérêt à lui
révéler honnêtement tout ce que vous
savez et au final le résultat du procès
sera sans doute tout aussi bien sinon
mieux que si vous aviez défendu votre
cas vous même en vous comportant de
manière pas tout à fait et éthiques
alors le problème c'est que pour vous
défendre de manière optimale l'avocat
lui devra faire des trucs qui sont pas
forcément éthiques
en tout cas dans la série soute pour
éviter de forcer quiconque à se
comporter de manière immorale
l'idée du principe de révélations et de
simuler un individu virtuel qui
joueraient le jeu pas forcément éthique
à la place de vous ou de votre avocat le
procès aura été exactement le même sauf
qu'il aura été entièrement simulé de
manière virtuelle de sorte que personne
n'aura eu à agir de manière immorale
en particulier vous tous que vous aurez
eu à faire c'est a révélé à la
simulation tout ce que vous savez et
préféré et de façon cruciale
vous avez tout intérêt à être honnête
pour que l'individu virtuel qui vous
représente puisse agir de la meilleure
façon possible pour vous et selon vous
je me les détails techniques ici pour
les matheux parmi vous sachiez que d'un
point de vue mathématique au final ce
n'est qu'une histoire de composition de
fonction alors comme je les dis le
principe de révélations permis de
construire des mécanismes incentive
compatibles mais il ne résout pas tous
les problèmes en particulier insiste sur
un point le principe de révélations ne
change pas l'issue du jeu si on
l'appliquait la crise de l'électricité
en californie bah ça fera encore une
crise de l'électricité en californie
l'intérêt du principe de révélations
c'est d'éviter aux joueurs dilemme
éthique et surtout d'éviter que les
joueurs éthique et honnêtes soient
défavorisées
du coup par exemple au foot il s'agirait
de donner un penalty à tout joueur qui
n'est pas tombé mais qui aurait pu
obtenir un penalty si la vessie
les et dans le cas du badminton bas il
s'agirait d'autoriser les gens a déclaré
forfait
bon c'est pas terrible pour le spectacle
l'idée du principe de révélations c'est
justement de simuler le spectacle pour
qu'il n'ait pas lieu en réalité et ne
calculait ainsi que le résultat du jeu
allez pour finir cette vidéo on va voir
si vous avez bien compris le principe de
révélations qu'obtient ton si on
applique le principe de révélations à
l'enchère classique celle où un bien est
vendu au plus offrant aux prix annoncés
par ceux plus offrant et juste pour être
clair je pars de l'enchère illustré par
cette publicité
[Musique]
je me sens
et bien si on applique le principe de
révélations à l'enchère classique on
obtient une enchère qui vend le bien au
plus offrant aux prix annoncés par le
second plus offrant c'est ce que l'on
appelle l'enchère au second prix elle a
été introduite académiquement par le
prix nobel d'économie williams vie créée
en 1961 et a longtemps été utilisé par
google pour vendre des publicités sur le
web
et bien sûr comme on l'a obtenue via le
principe de révélations on sait que les
acheteurs ont toujours intérêt à être
honnête dans la révélation du prix
qu'ils sont prêts à offrir
c'est à dire que tout acheteur dans une
enchère au second prix aura tout intérêt
à annoncer le vrai prix maximal qu'il
est prêt à dépenser pour acquérir le
bien et ça je vous invite à vous en
convaincre par vous même la 1ère fois on
a parlé du point de démarrage et en
particulier des mariages stable il a vu
ce que ça avec des carrés des triangles
et vous avez été nombreux à faire des
remarques humoristique sur les
différents carrés et les triangles
toutes ses formes géométriques
on peut dire que vous avez été en grande
forme et la norges et nous demandent si
on obtient lui même résultat si on
inverse les hommes et les femmes du ô la
place d'avoir des hommes qui demande en
mariage on a des femmes qui demande en
mariage et la réponse a été donnée par
frédéric m'assois notamment en fait même
si c'est un petit peu brutal pour eux
puisqu'ils se font souvent refoulés les
demandeurs en mariage sont en fait ceux
qui sont le mieux loti dans l'algorithme
de gameplay puisque en fait ils
finissent avec le meilleur choix
possible sachant que l'ensemble des
mariages doivent être stables
donc c'est la meilleure solution stable
possible pour mes inverse les femmes
elles obtiennent leur pire choix
possible ça ça nous amène à la remarque
d'alexandre chamina tu l'as remarqué que
ce genre d'algorithmes si on lui donne
des données qui sont pas tout à fait les
bonnes et bien est-ce que de quelques un
truc qui marche pas du tout et en
particulier dans le cas des mariages
stable de la part des femmes sachant
qu'elles ont leur pire choix possibles
dans les mariages stable on sent
qu'elles pourraient avoir intérêt à ne
pas révéler leur vraie préférence pour
jouer le système en fait dans
l'algorithme de geisha plaît si les
femmes sont honnêtes dans leur
révélation de préférence
alors les hommes ont intérêt à être
honnête pose aussi mais si les hommes
sont honnêtes
alors les femmes n'ont pas forcément
intérêt à être honnête
ça dépend des figurations du jeu mais il
ya de nombreux cas où les femmes ont en
fait intérêt à ne pas révéler leurs
préférences de manière honnête en
particules c'est-à-dire qu'elles
pourraient avoir intérêt à rejeter
quelqu'un parce qu'il est passé bien
respect que ça va créer plus de
compétitions pour d'autres familles ont
du coup rejeter des hommes qui vont du
coup devoir demander d'autre femme en
mariage
du coup en particules ça peut
redistribuer les cartes et ça peut faire
en sorte que certaines femmes sont mieux
lotis renom n'ayant pas révélé leur
vrais préférence que s'il avait été
honnête dans la révélation de préférence
et ça je pense que c'est un problème
très important et très générales dont on
conçoit des algorithmes et qui vont
prendre des décisions qui concernent
plusieurs parties prenantes et en
particulier lorsque les parties
prenantes vont devoir nous de fournir
les données pour pouvoir faire tourner
aux algorithmes
il faut vraiment toujours se demander si
les parties prenantes vous révéler des
vraies données ou si elles vont chercher
à manipuler le système auquel cas le
résultat a calculé par l'algorithme
correspondent pas du tout à nos
solutions comme le souhaiterait mais il
n'est que l'issue des interactions
stratégique entre les différentes
parties prenantes en particulier si j'en
reviens à nouveau au mariage stable
si les femmes commencent à se comporter
de façon malhonnête
alors les hommes pourraient avoir
intérêt aux aussi à s'implanter de
manière malhonnête et là ça peut [ __ ]
vraiment le bordel
caroline plouffe et lobbies aux nous
demandent ce qui se passe si maintenant
on autorise les mariages homosexuels
bien ce problème a été étudié par les
mathématiciens également donc
malheureusement les algorithmes sont
encore un peu plus compliqué à expliquer
tout fait pas les expliquer ici
mais sachez que pour le cas où il ya
juste des liens de compatibilité pas de
préférence mais juste d'élire de
compatibilité via un algorithme qui s
appelle l'algorithme de couplage de
edmund qui permet de résoudre ce
problème et des idées sont assez
d'ailleurs similaire algorithmes de ford
ferguson et j'ai écrit un article et
quelques années qui parle de cet
algorithme de couplage cesse pour
résoudre le problème des mariages avec
des liens de compatibilité qui seront
donc pas forcément stable dans le cas
des mariages stable il ya un autre
algorithme qui date de 1985 ago rythme
de irving le truc avec l'algorithme de
irving sait qu'il marche pas toujours
et pour une très bonne raison c'est que
en général il peut ne pas exister de
mariage stable dans le cas des mariage
monogame mais possiblement homosexuels
s'il existe une combinaison de mariage
stable alors l'algorithme de irving va
le calcul est ici n'existe pas de
mariage stable alors l'algorithme dire
ligne va quand même réussir à nous dire
qu'il n'en existe pas en effet enfin
vous avez pu constater que le nombre
d'abonnés a pas mal augmenté depuis la
semaine dernière c'est ça c'est grâce à
dr nordmann et le fait qu'il m'ait
invité à parler de théorie du chaos sur
sa chaîne
un grand merci au dr nordmann de m'avoir
invité et puis d'avoir fait une vidéo de
maths qui fait des millions de vues
classe je trouve où elle espère que vous
avez aimé cette vidéo la prochaine fois
on va parler d'enchères en particulier
on va parler de la meilleure enchère
possible enchères optimale de meilleurs
sound qui a permis au maire sont
différents de gagner le prix nobel
d'économie de 2007
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci au
deep purple ordre et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois les sportifs
qui suivent les valeurs olympiques sont
défavorisées car eux s'épuise le risque
donc de se faire éliminer de se blesser
ou pire encore de se mettre à adopter
des stratégies moins éthique qui
n'arrête pas de marquer